hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering all of your
property investment
questions so do me a favor though hit
the like button
smash subscribe turn on the notification
bell
so that you don't miss a future video
also if you've got
any questions at all anything nothing
too personal
comment below and i will answer your
property
investment questions last week we had
quite a few interesting questions last
week i had a guy called dpg
he said what do you do after you put an
offer through and it gets accepted in
terms of getting investors money
together
and the estate agent asking you to sign
contracts
um okay i don't know if you're talking
about packaging and selling deals
are you talking about packaging and
selling deals here
for you or for an investor so listen
to adventure okay
so you have the offer accepted but you
want to get the investors money
and you're saying how can i get the
investors money right yes so let's say
you put the offer in
yeah but then you need to raise the
finance
okay okay so if you put in a lot if
you're putting an offering on a property
before you put a formal offer forward
and get it accepted
you would probably want to get the
investor kind of on board have you got
that
yeah cool investors ready they just got
the money yeah
who's prop who's the name going in or is
it going a joint name joint company or
something
giant company so in that case all you
need to do is
the estate agent's going to ask to see
five things solicitors details
mortgage broker proof of funds
correspondence address and photo id so
you're just gonna have to just liaise
with your joint venture partner get
get those five things ready and then
when the offer is accepted
show you don't need to pay yeah you need
to show you've got the money ready
that makes sense got it yeah so get
those five things ready
get the investor to get them ready and
then as soon as the offer is accepted
show the evidence the money doesn't need
to be paid until you come to complete
which will be about two months down the
line anyway
uh if you need any more help give me a
shout matt holcroft
i have a question i've heard that you
can only you can only have an interest
mortgage for up to five years
after this you have to buy the property
is this true
no that's not true um that's not true
here's what's true after five years it
will just turn from a fixed rate to a
variable rate so let me give you an
example if the mortgage company says
i'll give you a hundred thousand pound
mortgage
you could fix it for five years on three
percent
three percent interest per year and then
after five years it will just go on to
the new
variable rate which could be more than
three percent
it could be five percent could be ten
and at that point you can either
re-mortgage and get a new lender
and then a new company will come in and
give you the hundred grand and then
you'll use that to pay off the old
company but now you have the new rates
i hope that makes sense uh okay gaming
elite
samuel are buying and renting out
caravans a good investment
i mean listen you could probably make a
lot of money
because you could probably borrow very
cheap
on a beach or something and rent it out
for quite a lot on
service accommodation airbnb however
the reason i like property so much is
because when you buy a property
bricks mortar foundations
in the ground it's going to last me a
thousand years
it's going to outlive me it's going to
outlive my kids it's going to outlive my
kids kids
by which time you can't keep passing
money down anyway
the government will just take you off
you okay a caravan
no a caravan's going to go down in value
it's going to depreciate
so property is an appreciating asset
that holds its value
and gives you rent a caravan is going to
give you rent maybe really good rent
maybe really but it's not gonna
appreciate so i probably would say no
next samuel could you suggest the best
way to get a mentor
yeah you probably need a mentor i'm
happy to be a mentor i will mentor you
my mentors will mentor you and
it's a one pound you can pay one pound
try out for seven days
and it's 95 pounds per month
there after join the mastermind join the
mentoring is crazy
i'll leave a link in the description so
you can join it's called samuel 365.
next carolyn pinnock what is a lease
option agreement a lease option
agreement
carolyn pinnock is when you buy a
property now but you agreed to pay for
it later
uh a way that i once sort of did it was
there was a property and the mortgage on
the property was 81 000 pounds
and they wanted about 85 grand there was
no equity
in it so i said instead of buying the
property how about this how about
you give me the property but i'll take
on your debt
there's no there's no profit in the
house anyway so give me the debt
and i'll take on your horrible nasty
debt namely your mortgage
but then i'll have the house for free
it's kind of like what it how it rolls
and how that how that was structured was
like a lease option it was a lease
option agreement
where i had the option to purchase the
property in seven years time for 81
grand
and in the meantime i inherited the
property i rented it out
the rent paid for the mortgage payments
plus more for me i kept that little bit
of extra money every month and then
after seven years i used that little bit
of money
and bought the house baby by which time
the house had gone up in value
but they could not sell it to anybody
else because i i had secured
an option agreement on it and i had a
restriction
on the title deeds they could not sell
it to anybody else apart from me
over those seven years hope that helps
next kieran calcutt
says i'm 17. do you think i should rent
a house to live in for a few years
a council house after a few years buy
the house
then move out to another council house
listen man you could do that
but then you're gonna have to live in
council houses your entire life i
probably wouldn't do that and then
they're probably
they might change the rules by the time
you get the right to buy anyway
tyler lewis any advice on what bank is
best to go for a mortgage with
don't go to a bank go to a mortgage
broker and now
be an independent broker go to an
independent mortgage broker
let them scan all the banks you don't
want to be going to a bank right slim
last question what do you think about
doing asap to get started in property do
you think i should wait and self-educate
myself more
or jump straight in if you think i
should just go for it what would you
recommend me to start
listen you need to
get trained alongside doing it
sometimes people think i'm gonna have a
batch on my own and see what happens
if you have a bash on your own without
support
you'll have a bash and you'll have a
crash other people think i want to train
and i want to know
everything before actually doing
anything no you can't know
everything before doing everything you
need to learn as you
earn together hope that was helpful
drop your questions below and i look
forward to seeing you guys next time